skulls were like we don't know they
could be baby skulls from the babies
they suck the blood from it says that no
I'm
around
town hey Tes welcome to another episode
of Dum people Town population you
population Roy Ben Roy welcome to the
show thank you for having me I love you
guys you know I'm here and there's
nothing in that none of that is real
he's tried to drink all of it I've tried
to drink all of it relapse time on D
people tried to drink the Moroccan
moraca this is an intervention we're
tired of you being sober yes a reverse
intervention we don't like sober Ben no
what if that was literally the whole
point of the show these cameras AR
intervention is come on we need a little
more wild time guys we need a dinner
vention how is that not a show on The
Cooking Network the dinner ven the din
vention she's been serving the same
stuff every week your carrots hurt me in
the following ways look I know I say
this and I said this last time you were
on dumb people town uh and I think we
were like you had just come out with it
but the 97.9 the rat race is one of my
favorite other podcasts that one of the
few that I listen to like outside of it
your
episode God unbelievable you all were
amazing yeah I mean there I'm not
blowing smoke just because I'm here like
the the the these two episodes are so
good and your a your accent and when the
car gets blown up out don't give it away
go no reason to worry about no reason to
worry about it so I want you to listen
to the show uh bookmark it do it we'll
talk about all this stuff later I got a
stories we got dumb stuff to get into
and I got the first story let me do this
right here okay first story sent in by I
don't think this person has sent it in
before and I love the name Deco
Resources LLC at decoor resources this
this your wife no like a
decoration or Art Deco I don't know but
whoever it is is sending us this dumb
story from their company I want this
guy's name to be Arthur know it's a guy
it could be a woman Arthur Deco Arthur
feels like a company that that like
poisons groundwater something like a
whole
water know was a large class action
against Deco resources they stoin Into
The Deco resource sounds like the
villainous company in Beverly Hills Cop
five exactly going to get him out of DCT
Victor Victor havos in all right all
right so you ready for this here's the
headline Jonathan Banks nor North
Catholic counselor loses job after
students get crystals from
self-proclaimed
witches wait hold on give it to did you
go to Catholic school did you go you did
give it to me one more time you will
love this Ben I'm so happy my son just
started Catholic High School wait give
this to me one more time nor North
Catholic counselor so person who's a
counselor North Catholic loses job at
North Catholic High School after
students get crystals from
self-proclaimed witches
[Laughter]
now which is kind of some shade to the
witches right because they might have
certif certifications I'm going to get
into this and I'm so happy you went to
again you never went to a Catholic
School ever ever it's it's there's just
a school right it's just Town High
School yeah yeah yeah there wasn't a lot
of choices in Roi what was the name of
your high school I I went to public high
school but my grade school middle school
was called Holy Infant Jesus stop it was
called h j Holy Infant Jesus Infant
Jesus Holy Infant Jesus it sounds like
an exclamation by the way you're going
to be saying that several times in the
middle of the story Holy Infant Jesus
here we go Pittsburgh
KDKA a coven of self-proclaimed witches
and Crystal witches and hoes and witches
and witches and crystals and crystals
with alleged special powers led to a
local Catholic High School counselor
apparently losing her job jez the women
who owned Elemental Magic spelled ma g i
c k yes why did they need oh because
because that's the way you spell them
the Druid type mag see these are things
I don't know not not David bla mag robes
not rabbits yeah exactly yeah thanks to
the distinction Elemental Magic robes
not rabbits robe Magic by the way robes
not rabbits would be a better name for
this not rabbits for God's sake in
Sewickley that sounds like a magical
name that's the township identify
themselves as witches okay NE
nonetheless they were invited to they
were invited to speak at a local
Catholic High School resulting in a
firestorm pitting Catholics versus pag
beliefs mhm now look I do think a lot of
[__] like religious Zeals in our
[__] world right however you still
have to know your audience
not at all Catholic school is up in arms
over witches selling crystals to kids if
you are the counselor of a Catholic
School understand what you can who you
can andamp audence it's the most know
your audience ever hey you you want the
witches or do we pay the extra money for
this is a classic rookie witch move here
you know what I mean it's clearly a
group of witches got a hold of some
product he say I'm going to go out I'm
going to go out with no training right
and it's why and is why there's a top
tier there's a top down kind The Witches
could have stopped this and they're
getting pressure from witch's corporate
they're like you guys aren't moving
these crystals they how many crystals
have you moved this month dude they're
getting than the Catholic schools and
you just start moving that Crystal unta
Market yeah they're getting pressure
from Deco resources it now in the in in
like the break room at at Deco resources
which is I'm sure where they were at
Magic they're like you'll never believe
what Penelope and they went to a
Catholic School to try to push crystals
but they were booked by the principal
right the counselor so who's obviously
going through a divorce she's going
she's going through a divorce and this
these group of women have helped her
through her life change and so she was
like no they
they live in the split level Town Home
complex they met at the pool yeah she
let them touch her nipple once just for
a minute and she got weirdly aroused and
she's like I believe a little bit in
Magic the three women say they're wicens
a coven of witches and for the past
seven years which I'm sure that's
significant for some reason by the way
isn't that what you say about a Salesman
I mean this guy can sell crystals to
Catholic you know what I'm saying I can
sell
crystal have a sales that's a great
sales person right they've been selling
crystals skulls and scented candles they
believe to be C candles why is that so
they believe to be imbued with special
powers from their store now that is
loose right from the store but like my
daughters love to buy crystals for
people and they're like if you this one
is for and my wife will be like I'm
lighting this green candle for wealth
and whatever and I'm just like okay this
how you end up burning hey you know what
happened after that
burning you're three cented candles away
from on the P if your kids are passing
crystals around you don't need to tell
me you've been to
burning light the scented candle what
happened after that we went into a
writer
strike but contrary to popular
Impressions these witches this is so
funny say they conjure no dark Forces so
they're here to tell you yeah we're in
the light we're selling crystals and
candles Wizard of Oz has a good witch
yeah robes not rabbits guys let's do
this all right you know they added the
skulls part just to make these women
seem worse than they are like if it's
just Crystal and scented candles that's
not a big deal but you add the skulls
they're like there's going I love that
Catholics get sanctimonious about like
skulls it's too much but the the
iconography of a of a crucified man
bleeding from his W okay so I'm glad
you're getting into this we'll get into
this a little bit later because I think
that's important too but like skulls are
like we don't know they could be baby
skulls from the babies they suck the
blood from it says that no I'm just oh
okay Weir how outraged you got latshaw
this is what Tabitha latshaw had to say
no absolutely we don't believe in that
we worship as wiccans we worship nature
so our elements are air earth water and
fire that's what we worship thanks and
Tabitha is like the best witch or wiced
name ever right NAA is like such a
wicked name wasn't that Bewitched right
yes yes that sounds right there you go
that I don't Samantha but the bab the
baby might have been Tabitha maybe
possibly Aaron's going to yell it out in
a second second I know he is just before
Christmas break a career and college
counselor at North Catholic High School
first of all don't be calling these
women around right before Christmas
either okay even as a Jew I know that
that's a bad that's a big time of year
right at North Catholic High School
invited the women to speak about
starting a small business in front of
her marketing class of a junior and of
Junior and senior students hey you want
to start a business how about these
pagans over here right oh my gosh all
all went okay until they gifted each
student a crystal this does sound like
act one of the next Hocus Pocus
it I watched hus Pocus too and I I
watched Hocus Pocus too Dan okay I'm
going to say this and I had to contain
myself from calling you to be like how
in the world did you ever like Hocus
Pocus one hocus po one is Great Dan hus
Pocus 2 erases everything that you loved
about H are are you he loves Hocus Pocus
Dan have you seen just magic Zary bins
is the greatest cat of all time Dan have
you seen just D magic don't get us into
The Sandlot argument okay that's a
people got mad at us cuz we said the
sand mad care all right look stop it D
that's where we better than that that's
where we kind of got we get off the
rails uh said Michelle Pudo the
secretary for Catholic schools wait
that's when it got off the rails when
they when they gifted the crystals to
the they gifted the cryst to the girls
as soon as this woman saw three Stevie
Nicks impersonators come walking through
the door that's when it went off the
rails not when you gifted them the thing
the first hey what do we have in here
for a program these three wiccans are
going to come and talk to our kids like
to me if there were satanists who ran
like a great taco truck we want to talk
to you guys about opening up your own
buiness like the tacos are so good A
Taste of the nether the down low right
how good with a Satanist T devil sauce I
don't know if it's in here but you know
this is going to end up in a like open
to the public school board meeting oh
God and I hope Chad and JT going busted
up all right right cross promotion uh
right before Christmas uh guys first of
all I want to give all the glory to the
man downstairs this is what the taco
truck people do all right so the
students in the class felt that things
were off so they did go directly to the
administrators wait the students why
because they tried to sell them crystals
they gave didn't work they probably knew
they were bunk like these are bad
crystals
cryst going give meid from a public
school selling [__] crystals to like to
like private school kids that's pretty
cool coven stuff that is good COV stuff
Crystal Method uh over break the
administration conducted an
investigation consulted with the dases
you know that that's oh good let's get
this old white dude into this and sent
an email of apology to parents and
Gardens advising them to return or
dispose of the Crystal this is where it
like becomes Foot Loose just let the
[__] people have the crystals like
you know there's nothing wrong don't get
the devil Crystal the witch crystal out
of there and Advising them to recite the
Prayer of St Michael the Archangel do
you know that prayer no thank you nope
uh to cleanse their homes Michelle Pudo
the Das and Director of Education said
they have no place in a Catholic school
or household shean said there was an
understanding that the crystals had
powers and that is antithetical to the
church's teaching Bill Davenport said
why can't we hire Jim cabel to come talk
to us
kids babo Hower a hand said I want a bar
downstairs wait what Bob in my house I
want a bar and during the day it should
be a Starbuck hey we're doing an
article Yi my time I yeld my time to the
rest of the board Pudo said it it is
because we know our faith is in Jesus
Christ the infant baby infant
holy Jesus Christ our faith in Jesus
Christ and not in objects necessarily
rosary beads other than other than these
beads in this rosary beads yes but
crystals no okay
so rosary beads these small circular
type things that are attached to it yeah
this is the scene from The Jerk none of
no things carry any power except except
these beads and cck are the body and
there crucifix that other than that else
other than but all the holy water and
the
sac that waving and then the Stations of
the Cross but that's it and those
candles that are the frankincense and
the myrr and that's it and these candles
these three nails that represent the
nails n of this but no nothing else but
your wicking crystals are destroying
everything how dare Tabernacle too don't
that's it and Mary's organ but fine but
that's these witches out of here you
leave Mary's organ out of this they told
them to either return to the school or
dispose of it and uh they're also
telling them to say the St Michael Arch
PL in the house God made these this is
what L latshaw says God made these they
came from the earth that's all I can say
this is what the wiccan said so I love
that the wiccan still believes in God
and she got that off of Wiccan pedia
that's right come on come on there
should be a
wik I'm Googling it to see if it exist
look up wiked look up wikin pedia it's
not I want you to go to god daddy or
whatever is relevant now and buy it
immed this is where the world gets dumb
okay this is where I get upset so she
had this person she hire she had these
three women who I'm assuming again three
women she man to take the gig dumb for
them to take the gig dumb for them to
give out the crystals and say that the
crystals have magical powers you don't
need to say that you can give everyone a
crystal just say hey this is from our
shop don't say that they have magical
powers like everybody screwed up along
the way that should be it maybe you call
the woman in and say hey you got to use
better judgment when you move down the
road know your audience you can do
whatever you want but like this is the
way we this school views this thing
right here and that's it by the way is
there a Wikipedia there is a wikin it's
a flicker it's a
flicker but of course that should be it
but the for the
counselor doesn't work the Fallout did
not end there but like we think Witches
by the way and wicens are like in the
black hat with the flowy black face the
Jewish nose like we all think that right
I mean those are your words no but I'm
telling you like you guys think that
right wik are just you know stev Nicks
fans yeah in like white wife beater
shirts and like and shorts and why they
life beers I'm looking at pictures of
wiccans and it's just Conant like white
tank tops and like they look like
they're on their in hiking shoes they
all look jug those are that's what those
are jug no that's an Indigo Girls
concert uh I don't know what I'm looking
at we followed our process and protocol
and as of today actually a few days
she's not with the school
anymore counselor is gone well I know
where she's going to start working over
at the you know what they she's in a I
tell you what she's in a like a concrete
cast you know what I mean in a in an
overpass Jersey if I'm her I putting
spells on this place like nobody's
business [__] throw the dark Crystals
at them a gag like she could have just
given the posit their positive crystals
just been like I snuck some positive
crystals on them and now they're walking
around with it and having a good day and
they think God did it not realizing G
power of
Crystal right so KD KD k a TV's Andy
Sheen spoke with the counselor involved
and said she was placed on a minist
leave after the incident and then given
the option to resign that that's when
someone's like get out of here you the
option uh she said she has no intention
of imparting had no intention of
imparting the beliefs of these women on
the students of North Catholic she's not
a bad person and of course like
everything the Catholic Church takes it
too far mhm I mean un it under the RO
but it depends relocator you've
relocated a lot worse can say to another
Catholic
School oh my God
slam relocated a lot worse and that is
the first thing uh when we come back
from break we'll let you guys know what
we have going on uh and what uh and then
much later in the show Dan and Ben uh
Ben's got a special out we'll talk about
all that stuff it's dumb people town
with Ben Roy don't go nowhere I mean
don't go any just stay where you
are
around hey guys welcome back to the show
before we get into the Second Story we
should just let people know super.com
right is where you can catch us and do
all the things and see us doing the
things that we love to do I believe when
this is coming out we're going to give
some distance cuz Ben Roy did uh our
fantastic show uh view from the cheap
seats and we want to give a little bit
so we get a bite of the apple of what
his thing and we'll talk about that in a
little bit but if this comes out before
September 13th or the 18th uh we have a
show on the 13th like that Ben did last
night as we're recording this at uh the
Comm store in the belly room called tag
so fun if you I'm going to tell people
if you haven't been to this you have to
go to this show it's so fun and so
you did your hilarious set of Comedy
which was by the way so awesome and so
different from everybody's set and we it
and we tagged your we just wrote tags
and they come out and they tagged but
there was so many slam dunk oh I'll keep
the Uso helicopter one but but uh there
were so many slam dunks on so many of
those those
other we had some great ones and it's
just the energy in the room is great so
our Comas do their sets we do the pitch
them tags so we're doing on the 13th at
which is a Wednesday at The Comedy Store
in the belly room 18th at Largo 13th has
Fitz Simmons and Ian carmell and jam Lee
and Melissa via Senor it's great and
then 18th at Largo is going to have
Kumil Nani uh patwal another big special
big special guest it's unannounced but
we'll be there in maybe one or two other
people so uh
supercars.net to trade single cheese
string what sended by Josh Mount Josh
Mount m o u a so he's trying to use a
billboard to sell one to trade if you've
been to Yong y n g YG Y and dundis
square this week you may have noticed
something strange a large billboard
advertising a single black diamond
cheese string up for trade what's a
cheese string yeah I think it's just
string cheese string cheese string
cheese okay you you the thing you this
comes from globalnews.ca okay thank you
I don't even know where Yan and Dundas
is isn't that the one that's toron
Toronto Toronto like young street and D
time young and Dundas yeah we know it
yeah it is like their Time Square
Toronto a toron you're going to buy that
big cheese I was down on dund let that
go though you know I mean cheese like
that this is what it looks like I was
down on Dundas and I saw their selling
one of those so you want to trade a
string cheese but you have money to pay
for this again I didn't even know that
trading string cheese is a thing I'll
trade you mine Haven you ever seen that
stuff where people see what they can
trade up to and they start it like
something very and they just keep
trading up and trading up to like is
that what happens if you've been y
dunger Square this week you may have
noticed a black diamond uh cheese string
up for trade Angel Domingo uhhuh
angeling okay who bought the advertising
space said he found the cheese string in
the refrigerator of his new home when he
moved to
Toronto this is like when you go to an
Airbnb or even like a hotel fridge and
there's still something in there from
the person before throw it away or if
it's fully packaged you eat it is it
how's it the quality of it look in the
photo I mean it looks a
little it looks like it has I mean there
image quality loss but that looks like a
double that's like a Twist no that's a
Twist that's why Jack Jack it's a it's a
jaby Jack Jack now this is okay at first
thought it was insane back now he's like
we're talking a colby jack yeah we're
talking about a kby jack he's like I'll
trade I'll trade a Pontiac Fiero for
that this is what the says for trade one
cheese string accepting trades for one
cheese string uh marble flavor still in
original packaging no low balls still in
original packaging like it's a Star Wars
action figure he wrote no no low balls I
know what I
have and did he have to say no fat
chicks I think that of like an Antique
Road Show just appraising and tell us
how you came well my grandfather was it
my grandfather's attic it was always a
door stop it was helping keep the attic
door and and then a draft dodg or so
youil War
buff packaging you know I'm looking at
some of the exactly some of the fonts
and these are fonts that came along a
lot later now we priced this through
where we have and I mean has anybody
appraised it for you no I have no idea
so you have no clue so our appraiser sat
down and said it is worth next to
nothing now it has been out of the
fridge just just on this show it has
been out of the fridge for an hour so
now it contains diseas was a guy on
there's two Antique Road Show stories
that are two of my favorites one of them
is a Tik Tok I think I could send it to
you the first one is a guy got out of
Vietnam bought himself a Rolex watch and
put it in his bank safe deposit box
never touched it my God never touched it
sat there for 40 years MH then he took
it to an Antiques Road Show and it is
worth I think like $880,000
something they're like the because it
was a rare type that he didn't know that
it was you know limited
like so then um the other one is this
elderly woman she's probably 87 years
old they're like in Pennsylvania and he
and she's standing next to the guy and
in between the two of them is like a
little decorative plate right with a dog
on it and he goes can you tell us what
what you have here and she says well
when I was 11 years old it was like you
know
1941 something 1904 when I was 11 years
old um a man tried to kidnap me and our
our family dog uh jumped the fence and
attacked the man and I was saved and it
got written up in the local paper and
then the governor invited us to uh the
governor's mansion to the capital or
whatever and she goes and they had a
commemorative plate made for our family
dog and he was named dog of the year so
this dates to like 1941 and he was named
dog of the year and my family's kept it
ever since and he the guy goes okay well
we've taken a look at it um it is not
worth any
money and the woman just kind of goes oh
and he's like now but to you it's pric
she's like and like you should never get
rid of it well he saved me and she right
why are you getting a value why are you
getting it a else at all I don't think
you understand your memories are worth
nothing to the they're worth everything
to you and nothing to the world this
cheese stick is a commemorative dog
plate you got a 75-year-old plate with a
dog on that's what youve got all right
good she but that woman came in like
this is going to be worth like she came
in hot she's like
she it was dog of the year how many of
those are there there's only one each
year I don't think you heard he saved me
dog of the year of the year I'm going to
kidnap your hearts with this story of
the Year okay so he goes I moved into
this place in Toronto I found the trees
string he told Global News why are they
covering this I have no idea Global he
regularly trades items on resell
websites such as Ki G I don't know and
decided he would try to do the same with
this piece of cheese Domingo said he's
used to trading Vehicles car parts or
furniture on resell websites but said
the market is filled up with all kinds
of strange things this is probably the
strangest thing that I've ever had to
offer up somebody told me it's not that
strange it's not woman farts and jar and
sell there was a viral person who
started with a paperclip and I think got
all the way up to a car like trading
people cuz at one point they would get
like a skateboard and somebody was like
oh my God that skateboard is actually
worth a few hundred doar I'll trade you
this old laptop and so they're just
lucky and they just yeah they just keep
putting it out like I'm willing to trade
willing to trade until they get they got
a car
that's unbelievable uh somebody told me
uh I wouldn't be able to get anything
for it and nobody would want it but I
guess some people really want it Domingo
said since the billboard went up he's
been receiving offers in droves not a
word you see very I received a lot of
offers that's idiotic some people are
calling me again because the first offer
they had wasn't good enough I think most
anybody had to offer me
was two Persian cats what now that is
somebody if they don't want the string
cheese they just don't want these cats
got get rid of the cats this guy's
offering one stick of string cheese just
throwing the [__] at Domingo said as
of Thursday afternoon he had not
accepted any offers I've been telling
anybody the same thing when they ask me
what I'm looking for it's like you'll
know it when you see it so this he
Tipper Gore in if if if he gets the
Persian cats and I'm the people who give
the Persian cats up as I'm walking away
as I'm literally out the door I say they
really love string cheese just walk out
there they only eat that I leave yeah
colby jack he said he hasn't heard the
right offer yet there's been a lot of
offers and a lot of it's just fluff
you're the one offering string the most
fluffy thing on I don't think you're in
a position to say what's fluff or not
there hasn't been any quality he said uh
Domingo said he dead paid a lot of money
to put the put the billboard up but
would not disclose the total amount he
said the contract for the advertising
space is only for a few weeks worth it
according to Domingo the cheese string
is still editable with its expiry date
still a few months out black diamond
string chees are widely available at
most grocery store locations how do we
know that that's okay how do we know
that that's the original one in the
thing you could have bought a whole pack
right and just traded a whole bunch of
people nobody would know no one would
know one of the things I want to do the
story one ridic the dumbest thing that
would happen in dumb people Tom if
anyone in Toronto can tell me what this
ended up going for or they if they
traded for it like now get in the game
you get off but the thing is now this is
famous like now this has increased its
tradein value yeah I would trade I would
trade it for just a regular mozzarella
cheese stick you would go straight up
one chees an eye for an eye you don't
think he'd go no there's two cheeses and
it's twisted I found this in the outside
fridge of the place that I just
left come on that's Story number two my
friends W that is just
stupidity hilariously stupid all right
Jay can you give us just a small smidgen
of a taste of what we're going to hear
in in segment three uh if you're going
to steal stuff from someone's porch uh
best get ready you better have a better
disguise that's okay good to know that's
good to know all right that's Story
three we'll find out what uh about Ben
special and we'll find out what Dan's
got going on right after this it's done
people tell with Ben Roy
hey guys welcome back to the show before
Jay takes us home uh Daniel and before
we talk about Ben special Dan uh where
can people see you and I know you you're
in the middle of it all I'll be at High
Plains Comedy Festival September like
21st 22 something like that and then I'm
also headlining the yuck Festival in
Boston on October 20th but in addition
to that if you're in anywhere in the
midwest uh Michigan Indiana Illinois
Wisconsin and then in the South Texas
and the East Coast I've got like 25
dates coming up everything's at Daniel
van kirk.com all leading up to my
special an album recording on 1111 at
the Lincoln Lodge in Chicago that's
Saturday night go to Daniel van.com and
if you come out to a show and you're
Towny bring a headline cuz I kick off
the show by uh asking if anybody has one
and then we'll goof around a little bit
and then I'll bring out the house so i'
love to see ton out there I got a
headline for you it's a a young young
buck over here releases standup special
on YouTube and it
seeming it's called hyena it's on
YouTube and it's amazing and I we told
all of our fans on uh view from the chap
seies to go check it out and now we're
telling you dumb people Town fans this a
great way to support Comics certainly
during a writer strike and an actor
strike yes uh he put this out himself it
is on YouTube what do you do I put it
out with 800lb Gorilla 8B gorilla sorry
you put it out with them yep but the
goal is to try to get it as many views
as possible sure positive reviews give
it a thumbs up watch it share it with
friends that is how we help Comics like
him and like us who knows down the line
get our shows up in the world we create
a network of people who support comedy
and then that launches you all are the
best sweet I love you so happy guys yeah
thanks I'm psyched I'm psyched for this
hyena Hy to remember hyena H filmed it
one of the best comedy clubs in the
country Comedy Works downtown beautiful
Comedy Works Denver and they built you a
special background for yeah it's cool
it's all they did an amazing job all
right comy works that's it we got to get
it I want this next story bringing J
bring us home tpd which uh I don't know
what that stands for Tulsa Police
Department okay uh man arrested after
being recognized wearing underwear as
mask in porch pirate cases okay cases
cases wear a regular masks like are
masks are still easy to get have you had
[__] stolen from from your house that
was delivered oh yeah yeah yeah I don't
know why nobody on their face I don't
know why that makes me so mad it makes
me so it's such a violation it's like
it's yeah I just hate theft like
thieving things I just is bad thiing
from your porch is really bad but if
you're going to do it Ste don't wear
underwear on your face like a dumb ass I
mean that's that's steal up steal from
Walmart no I'm just kid that's my thing
too is like Amazon you don't even know
what you're getting no like oh you
wanted this kitty litter yeah ex here's
this here's this clay that I have to get
my dog so [__] is open it up look in
there you might go oh I don't need
deodorant have it yeah have have at
those dishwasher pods you we start a
deal where once you get in the car and
open it and you realize what it is if
you really can't use it or sell it bring
it back yes bring it back and say I'm
sorry to my ring take the underwear off
your face and say yourself so Tulsa
Police sparman has arrested an alleged
porch pirate with unusual and
questionably effective mask uh the Tulsa
Police Department has arrested uh okay
here we go they said that they were made
aware of a porch pirate case in west
Tulsa on January 6th we all remember
what happened on January remember on
that porch on January 6 this guy
hador the porch porch stor por of a big
white house uh according to TPT uh they
were provided with surveillance images
of the suspect and the flock safety
system what is a flock lock safety
system probably like a a ring it just
must be a company ring camera yeah I
every time you keep saying the uh
acronym for this Police Department it's
just our initials backwards and so I I
DPT tpd oh wow DPT it's dumb people town
which would be what would happen in dumb
people town if like the sheriff or like
the city council president was like
dyslexic so they accidentally ordered
all of these like welcome back tpd tpd
and I like that backwards it's Town
people dumb people which also works yeah
which works Town people
dumb it's it's like almost how like Yoda
would
introduc uh tpd DPT also said that uh an
officer recognized the suspect from
previous porch pirate cases where the
suspect was wearing women's underwear
women's probably a song you dumbass just
one little thing over your nose does it
does it show the it didn't but like they
were skims and and skims are so good
people are loving skim you know what a
what a Hanish crime I
know I think I think some real big
charges are looming come on I'm crushing
it guys you're being fruity right now we
go look they Crack the Case uh all right
Daniel come
on trapped
traa there is uh he did a [__] job uh
Snappy tpd they went to the suspect's
Home west of Nothing But a G string
baby they went to the suspect that
should have been the title if it was the
New York Post Ain't Nothing But a G you
knew that would have been the title in
the New York Post Ain nothing according
to tpd they went to the suspect's home
uh of West which is west of downtown
Tulsa knocked on the door and saw the
suspect this guy's name still wearing
them what's his name what's his name
give me it this is the most the guy who
would put underwear on his face Elroy
what you guess Elroy Jeffrey hibbon I'm
gonna say it's um oh God Herbert uh
dinker
ton you guys you're close in your own
way really he is uh
Sebastian you think of Sebastian would
do this Sebastian Sebastian
lastic
ready Spencer googler
oh you know we going to house this
weekend stealing Stu has been on a just
get crazy and put wear his girlfriend's
underwear on
his out sounds like a car like a guy who
brought food into 97.9 The Rat
Race the big one coming in with the
lasag it's just about 25 minutes we got
got Googs from bleacher Sports going to
be coming in as you know it is a time
check right now give us a time check
right now it's 25 minutes past it's 14
till a quarter before 15 past the hour
out there and a beautiful warning in the
Metro what's the traffic uh out on the
the i76 71 in the Beltway Corridor are
closed right
now what's going on with that uh that
underwear thief the porch pirate the gos
the gos is still out there no one's got
them yet of course metro PD say there
are the case right now but this is a
tough one
uh especially when when never
mind all right uh they okay so they go
to his house they knock on his door gos
tpd said googler remained inside the
home and would not talk to officers oh
my God googler barricaded himself I love
that go the
gos the Googs force their hand also I
love that a guy who steals things off
people's porches has now got a problem
on his own front porch with police on
his porch yeah like you know you should
be here it is violation my porch you
guys are making me feel very victimized
by coming onto my property against my
will yes I put underwear on my face and
yes I stole other people's items but you
know what you're you're making me very
angry right
now according to tpd a search warrant
for the home was obtained and signed
after the warrant was signed goler
exited the home MH TBD say guler was
arrested and booked for how many counts
of Larsen how many times did he take it
to the porch take it to the porch are
you asking us to guess I'm asking you to
guess you going you can go first get
inside the Googs mind how many did he
away with before they got him that's
many they're charging yeah I mean how
many do they have on God I don't want to
um I cuz is the closest without going
over no okay
okay 11 that's my guess I like that 27
counts of
larsy seven get your answers in one of
you is pretty close Okay shout at your
ham radios the Googs was arrested and
book for five counts wow wow gos didn't
get far every time he stole something he
just yelled at the porch Google it
Google it that Al what you just said is
the first line of his eulogy you know
the Googs didn't get far guys
and gos never fulfilled his prophecy as
he had laid ended up on the porch of
Life all
I'm going to give you an acronym Google
it uh I'm going to give you an acronym
for the crime and see if you guys can
guess it this is a new game we've never
done this before so so this I'm going to
give you the acronym and see if you can
guess related to the theft okay okay
kcsp what does that stand for K
kcsp
KC s and it is related to the crime okay
it is an acronym the K I can't get I
can't get
klepto like but oo but I I doubt that
that would be a legal term keeping
stolen kcsp keeping keep Contraband or
stolen props what you something you say
keeping control stolen keeping
controlled subst what is it KCs keeping
keeping control of stolen property
that's so good that's so good keeping
control control is weird
keeping you guys two of them right you
have two of them right I want you to
keep stolen property knowingly knowingly
yes you have three right three out of
four right
knowingly it's KC
KC knowingly you have SNP you have ksnp
right knowingly well I love ksnp that's
a
Frid all country now is new country and
big format change down there that's
they're still reeling
carrying stolen property knowingly
carrying stolen properly carrying stolen
knowingly what stolen property oh God
that's tough
knowingly there are townies yelling at
their phon yeah exactly think of a a law
connected I'll give you a hint I'll give
you a hint
thinking no think of a law associated
with weapons Contraband concealing
conal yelled it
KSP if you're nasty Grand larsy that's
Story number three there you go there
you go that was a good one that was so
fun and I love that we got a little bit
of the old rat ra on well that's a big
one and you always want to and make sure
guys uh if you're planning on coming
down to eek at the creek 6 this weekend
uh it's going to be a big weekend of
course our friends from Darkstar Brewing
are they going to have some of their
hard Siders are they going to have some
of the do they they bringing some of the
soft Siders they're bringing some their
soft Siders for the kiddos and some of
the hard Siders for some of the parents
so make sure you bundle up those it's
going to be a cold one
out soft Sid for the kiddos got soft
Family Affair it's put that put that
underwear on your nose and come on up to
the front por the
Google Jesus the goog
holy Jesus the googler is here uh the
name of the special is hyena he's Ben
Roy watch it review it pass it along we
love you guys so much and oh [__] we got
to get back to work
sck around make a sound there's more
[Music]
to